australia's prime minister has condemned
a fake image posted by
china depicting an australian soldier
apparently murdering
an afghan child australia has demanded
china apologize for the picture which
was
posted on a government twitter account
meanwhile china has urged australia to
apologize
to the afghan people it follows a report
earlier this month about the conduct of
australian soldiers
in afghanistan it's the latest in a
series of disputes
between the two major trading partners
i spoke to journalist roger maynard in
sydney he had
more on the australian prime minister's
furious reaction to the chinese twitter
post
um he branded the image uh as as
repugnant uh
and he demanded what he called this
truly offensive image
be removed from the social media site
and he demanded an immediate apology for
what he described as
an outrageous and disgusting slur
now the the post alludes to the
findings of a report uh into the alleged
murder of afghan civilians and prisoners
of war
by members of australia's elite special
air services group
while they were based in afghanistan
several years ago
now these allegations have not been
proven in a court of law
and china's insensitive response
has had the capacity to further damage
relations quite seriously
between the two countries uh a furious
morrison
said the chinese government should be
totally ashamed of
this post roger these two countries are
a big trading partners is there any sign
either side
will try to make amends
well uh not at the moment certainly um
the the row will further
obviously further damage relations
between canberra and beijing
both countries are in the middle of a
trade war at the moment
which has led to the suspension of
australian exports including
beef and barley shellfish timber and
wine
and china is one of australia's if not
australia's biggest export
market with sales of coal and iron ore
and agricultural goods worth billions
of dollars so there's obviously a lot at
stake here
if things deteriorate any further
roger maynard in sydney thank you for
that
thank you